I think it's really important that we
have rules and regulations and
transparency so that wherever anybody
accepts Hospitality we know what's
happened but with Scott Benton what
you've seen is a flagrant disregard of
those rules of those principles and it's
not a one-off only a few weeks ago we
saw three other Tori MPS looking after
lucrative jobs thousands of pounds at a
time for their parent advice and I think
all of this shows that the prime
minister's lost a grip
um and you know if ever we needed
further Evidence this is it that Tori
sleaze is back
would you support a new law Banning
under 25s from betting more than two
pounds a spin on the slot machine I
think we need to look at whatever
proposals the government put forward the
last legislation was nearly 20 years ago
now and online gambling has now come
along it's exploded and we haven't got
proper regulation so we do think
regulations need to be tightened we'll
look at what the government puts forward
but in answer the question do we think
this needs an update on further
regulation then yes we do MPS say
they're not expecting the government to
heed campaigners calls for a total ban
on gambling advertising is that
something you'd like to see well I think
we need to look at what proposals the
government put forward I do think that
nearly 20 years after large legislation
it is time to look again to tighten
those regulations I think there's a real
concern about online gambling this
wasn't really such a big thing 20 years
ago it's now huge and there are all
sorts of examples that need much much
tighter regulation wasn't it new labor
that relaxed gambling laws in this
country in the first place well new
labor back when in the day we're
regulating a different environment the
landscape has changed but I have to say
that this constant attempt by the
government to sort of blame the last
Labor government for everything it
really doesn't work if you've been in
power for 13 years I think the Public's
say well look if there's a problem you
really should have fixed it by now
do labor support the use of barges to
house migrants what's the alternative if
not
this is
certainly evidence of failure the
government has caused a situation where
they've broken the Asylum system got
thousands upon thousands of claims that
haven't been processed and the answer
isn't more expense for the taxpayer the
answer is to fix the problem stop the
boats with effective action and process
the claims and I think anybody listening
to this would be absolutely astonished
to learn that of all those that arrive
by small boats in the last year only one
percent have had their Asylum claims
process so the fundamental question for
the government is stop the boats in the
first place and process the claims that
are here the other arguments about
simply how you spend even more taxpayers
money and I think there's a real
frustration now the problem is process
the claims and the government needs to
get a group of that and get on with it